sixteen-year-old pets was raised by his
activist grandmother
and he didn't hesitate in joining the
student protest movement when it began
earlier this year this week he took part
in an act of civil disobedience
organized by the group
bad students many refused to wear
official school uniforms to class
this was to highlight inequality and to
call for reforms in thailand's education
system
petch had a black uniform made and
displayed rubber ducks
which has now become a symbol for the
protests
after being questioned for three hours
by teachers he was sent home
it's not only about the uniform rules
haircut rules it's about body rights
the expression of political opinions and
the education system
and subjects need to be reformed these
would be victories for us
protesters were out in big numbers on
wednesday after the constitutional court
unanimously
acquitted prime minister prey chenoucha
of violating ethics standards
ruling that it was not illegal for the
prime minister a former army chief of
staff
to live in a house on an army base while
the protesters here would have welcomed
a guilty verdict for the prime minister
they vow to carry on their fight to see
that their demands are fulfilled and
that is that the prime minister resigned
there's a new draft to the constitution
and that there's reform within the
monarchy
has been the focus of more rallies this
week first targeting his estimated 30
billion dollar fortune
thousands gathered at the headquarters
of one of the biggest banks in thailand
the king's the largest shareholder
personally owning 23 percent
and then a protest was held in front of
the royal guards barracks demanding that
the king give up his command
of two army regiments he took over when
he ascended to the throne two years ago
at the same time he also shifted the
crown's wealth to him
personally for the first time in two
years officials
issued warrants to protest leaders under
article 112
harsh defamation laws designed to
protect the monarchy
charged multiple times under that law
but never convicted sulak siwalak
has criticized action taken against
protesters
he has met with a king in the past and
says that it's key for him to engage
with the protesters
his position is not as secure as he
thought
and he tried to be popular but so far he
had not managed
to confront those who supposed to be
against him
and i feel that if he would be willing
to
confront those who declared himself to
be again a monarchy
i think that would help him but so far
the king has not
taken that advice while he has been
making public appearances
they've only been with those who support
him and the monarchy
and there's been no official palace
statement on the protests
scott heidler al-jazeera bangkok